veamos si podemos convertir 612 a vos 62
ya vos a un número decimal nuevamente te
invito a que intentes encontrar la
solución por tu cuenta te voy a dar una
ayuda convierte 62 ya vos a una fracción
con denominador 10
visualicemos esta fracción digamos que
este es un doceavo voy a hacer un entero
con 12 doceavos para eso voy a marcar
voy a copiar y pegar
ahí tenemos 22 ya vos en un momento voy
a iluminar algunos vuelvo a pegar
tenemos 32 ya vos de hecho ahora voy a
copiar los tres juntos
a copiar 312 a vos
y pego y ahí tenemos 62 ya vos
ahora tenemos 9 12 a vos
y finalmente tenemos 12 12 a vos en un
momento los voy a iluminar y lo que nos
interesa son 6 12 a vos veamos cómo
podemos representar 612 amos aquí voy a
iluminar los
voy a iluminar 62 ya vos
aquí tenemos dejan de utilizar un
marcador más grueso
aquí tenemos 456 doceavos aquí tenemos
voy a iluminar los bien que me queden
parejos
aquí tenemos 62 ya vos y la pregunta es
cómo podemos transformar estos 62 ya vos
a decimos algo que podemos hacer aquí es
considerar que 6 y 12 son ambos
divisibles entre 6 qué tal si en vez de
dividido en décimos mi dibujo lo expresó
en términos de mitades y cómo hacemos
eso bien podemos ver podemos ver que
esta parte de aquí corresponde a una
mitad y esta es la otra mitad otra
manera de ver esto es que estamos
juntando seis de esos dos ya vos los
cuales convertimos en una mitad ahora en
términos de las partes que tenemos
estamos dividiendo el número de partes
entre seis hagamos eso estamos
dividiendo en nueve partes que tenemos
entre seis y
ahora sólo vamos a tener dos partes
ahora sólo tenemos dos mitades esta de
aquí es una mitad
esta es una mitad y esta es la otra
mitad y observa que cuando teníamos 12
partes y tomamos seis juntas obtuvimos
dos mitades qué pasa ahora con seis
partes bueno vamos a hacer lo mismo
de esas seis partes vamos a tomar seis
partes juntas
vamos a tomar seis partes juntas es
decir vamos a dividir entre seis y vamos
a obtener una mitad que es esta que
tenemos aquí esta mitad es la que
corresponde a los seis doceavos
originales y observa que en ocasiones
anteriores hemos multiplicado tanto el
denominador como el numerador por un
mismo número para obtener una fracción
equivalente ahora lo que estamos
haciendo es dividir el numerador y el
denominador entre un mismo número y
obtener una fracción equivalente espero
que así quede claro como estos 6
doceavos equivalen a un medio ahora
porque hice eso no quedamos que
queríamos convertir
decimos claro que la queremos convertir
y un medio es un número muy fácil de
transformar a decimos veamos cómo
podemos convertir un medio así es que un
medio un medio vamos a visualizarlo aquí
un medio lo voy a representar voy a
ponerlo mejor acá arriba donde hicimos
nuestro dibujo anterior
aquí tenemos claramente esto va a ser
un entero aquí tenemos de nueva cuenta
un entero
como el que teníamos aquí abajo lo
estamos replicando y esta es la mitad
que obtuvimos que ya vimos que es
equivalente a 6 12 años así es que esta
es una mitad y para poder transformar
esa mitad a decimos vamos a dividir todo
el entero en cinco partes vamos a
dividir todo este entero en cinco partes
aquí tenemos una quinta parte aquí hay
otra
una tercera quinta parte y finalmente la
cuarta
y la quinta que hice ahora he
multiplicado el número de partes que
teníamos por 5 tenemos 5 veces el número
de partes y la mitad representa cinco de
esas décimas
así es que esto va a ser igual a 5 sobre
5 sobre 10 déjame hacer lo mejor con
verde 5 decimos 6 12 a vos equivale a un
medio y un medio equivale a 5 decimos
que hice aquí multiplique el numerador y
el denominador por 5 para obtener que un
medio equivale a 5 décimos y 5 decimos
lo podemos escribir como 5 por un décimo
es exactamente lo mismo y esto lo
podemos escribir como un número decimal
esto es igual a cero punto recordemos
que este es el lugar de las unidades y
el lugar que está justo a la derecha del
punto decimal es el lugar de las décimas
y tenemos cinco décimas así es que
tenemos cinco en el lugar de las décimas
así es que este número se puede escribir
en notación decimal como 0.5 0.5 y hay
muchas maneras de haber hecho esto
podría ser considerado que 6 es la mitad
de 12 como 5 es la mitad de 10 lo cual
se puede notar como 5 decimos que puedes
escribir como 5
por un décimo y que en notación decimal
se escribe como 0.5